don't you just hate waiting till
February 14th to celebrate Valentine's
Day well if you're a PlayStation Plus
subscriber your love of Sony will get
you some free games at the start of the
month if you want to know what's on the
list
I've got you covered first up ps4
players are getting another chance to
play one of the consoles launch titles
knack is all about changing size
fighting monsters and platforming and if
you remember the reviews when it first
released free does seem like the right
price ps4 is also getting last year's
adventure game rime a young boy has come
to a mysterious island to find his
missing father but it seems like the
world is filled with nothing but puzzles
you'll have plenty to solve as you
manipulate objects and change your
perspective but wait there's more Sony's
celebration of PlayStation VR continues
with another free game star blood arena
if you've got the headset you can strap
into a variety of different ships for
outer space dogfighting or take flight
with a friend in coop on the ps3 side
you can explore the world beneath your
feet in spelunker HD this is a remake of
the 80s NES game but you can still
toggle back to that 8-bit look if you
want it also comes with a hundred new
levels and some new environments if
you'd rather conquer all worlds instead
of just the underworld ps3 is also
getting Mugen souls II it puts you in
the shoes of the goddess ciaochao whose
goal is to conquer all 12 zodiac worlds
and there's plenty of hardcore RPG
combat to come during the conquest as
for the Vita Sony's handheld is getting
exiles end this side-scrolling
platformer is definitely a no Maj but
don't mistake it for a Metroidvania
it's all about moving through the levels
using all your wits and weapons to take
down the armies of monsters in your way
and finally Vita owners can also get
tactical with Grand Kingdom you'll have
to plan each move in these turn-based
battles especially when every unit has
unique abilities
thanks to cross buy you can also dig
into Grand Kingdom on ps4 and those are
your free PS Plus games for February
they'll be available from Tuesday
February 6th through March 5th you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles over 8 GameSpot
2
and if you want to keep up with all of
our top stories you can grab the
official game spot now app on iOS and
Android
[Music]
you